Cuando mi padre y yo comenzamos una compañía
para imprimir tejidos y órganos humanos en 3D,
algunas personas inicialmente pensaron que estábamos un poco locos.
Pero desde entonces, se ha progresado mucho,
en nuestro laboratorio y en otros laboratorios alrededor del mundo.
Y así empezamos a recibir preguntas como:
"¿Si pueden desarrollar partes del cuerpo humano,
podrán también hacer productos de origen animal como carne y cuero?"
Cuando alguien me lo sugirió por primera vez,
francamente pensé que estaban medio locos,
pero pronto me di cuenta que
no era algo tan descabellado, después de todo.
Lo descabellado es lo que hacemos hoy en día.
Estoy convencido que en 30 años,
cuando miremos atrás hacia el día de hoy,
la forma como criamos y sacrificamos miles de millones de animales
para hacer nuestras hamburguesas y carteras,
veremos esto como un desperdicio,
una locura.
¿Sabían que hoy en día se mantiene
una manada global de 60 mil millones de animales
para proveernos de carne, lácteos, huevos y productos de cuero?
Y en las próximas décadas,
cuando la población mundial alcance los 10 mil millones de habitantes,
el número de animales casi tendrá que duplicarse
hasta los 100 mil millones.
Mantener esta manada
implica un enorme costo para el planeta.
Los animales no son sólo materias primas.
Son seres vivos,
y ya el ganado
es uno de los mayores usuarios de la tierra
y del agua dulce,
uno de los mayores productores de gases de efecto invernadero
que impulsan el cambio climático.
Además de esto,
tantos animales hacinados
son caldos de cultivo para enfermedades
y generan oportunidades para el daño y los malos tratos.
Está claro que no podemos seguir por este camino
que pone al medio ambiente, la salud pública
y la seguridad alimentaria, en riesgo.
Existe alternativa porque, en esencia,
los productos de origen animal son sólo colecciones de tejidos.
En este momento reproducimos y criamos
animales altamente complejos
sólo para crear productos
formados por tejidos relativamente simples.
¿Qué pasa si en lugar de comenzar a partir de un animal
complejo y sensible,
empezamos con la materia de la que están hechos los tejidos,
la unidad básica de la vida,
la célula?
Esta es la biofabricación, donde las células mismas se utilizan
para desarrollar productos biológicos
como tejidos y órganos.
Ya en medicina,
se usan técnicas de biofabricación
para desarrollar partes complejas del cuerpo,
como orejas, tráqueas, piel, vasos sanguíneos y huesos,
que se implantan con éxito en pacientes.
Y más allá de la medicina, la biofabricación puede ser
una industria nueva que es humanitaria, sostenible y escalable.
Debemos empezar por reinventar el cuero.
Hago hincapié en el cuero porque se utiliza ampliamente.
Es hermoso y ha sido durante mucho tiempo parte de nuestra historia.
Técnicamente, el cultivo del cuero también es más simple
que el de otros productos de origen animal como la carne.
Utiliza practicamente un sólo tipo de célula,
y sólo tiene dos dimensiones.
También es menos polarizante para los consumidores y los reguladores.
Hasta que se entienda mejor la biofabricación
es evidente que, al menos inicialmente,
habrá más personas dispuestas a vestirse con materiales novedosos
que las inclinadas a probar alimentos diferentes,
sin importar lo deliciosos que sean.
En este sentido, el cuero es la puerta de entrada,
el comienzo para la industria principal de biofabricación.
Si tenemos éxito aquí
otros productos biológicos de consumo, como la carne,
estarán más cercanos en el futuro.
Ahora, ¿cómo lo hacemos?
Para cultivar cuero comenzamos tomando las células
de un animal a través de una simple biopsia.
El animal puede ser una vaca,
un cordero, o incluso algo más exótico.
Este proceso no causa daño,
y la vaca Daisy puede seguir feliz con su vida.
Luego aislamos las células de la piel
y las multiplicamos en un medio de cultivo celular.
Esto toma millones de células
y las expande a miles de millones.
Luego se estimulan las células para que produzcan colágeno,
como harían naturalmente.
El colágeno es el material entre las células.
Es el tejido conectivo natural.
Es la matriz intercelular,
pero en el cuero es el componente principal.
Lo siguiente es que tomamos las células y su colágeno
y las extendemos para formar láminas delgadas,
que luego ponemos una sobre otra,
como la pasta filo, para formar hojas más gruesas,
y luego lo dejamos madurar.
Por último, tomamos ésta piel de varias capas
y a través de un proceso de curtido más corto y menos químico,
creamos el cuero.
Estoy muy emocionado de mostrarles
por primera vez
nuestro primer lote de cuero cultivado
recién salido del laboratorio.
Esto es cuero real y genuino
sin sacrificio de animales.
Puede tener todas las características del cuero
ya que está hecho de las mismas células,
y mejor aún,
no tiene pelo que eliminar,
ni cicatrices o picaduras de insectos,
ni residuos.
Este cuero se puede moldear en la forma de una cartera,
un bolso o un asiento de auto.
No está limitado por la forma irregular de la vaca
o el cocodrilo.
Y como lo creamos
y cultivamos desde el principio
podemos controlar sus propiedades de forma muy interesante.
Este trozo de cuero
tiene apenas un grosor de siete capas
y, como pueden ver, es casi transparente.
Este tiene un grosor de 21 capas y es bastante opaco.
No se tiene ese tipo de control minucioso
con el cuero convencional.
Podemos ajustar otras cualidades deseables en el cuero
como la suavidad, la respirabilidad,
la durabilidad, la elasticidad, e incluso el dibujo.
Podemos imitar a la naturaleza,
pero en cierto modo también mejorarla.
Este tipo de piel puede hacer lo mismo que el cuero de hoy en día hace
pero, con imaginación, quizás mucho más.
¿Cómo se verán en el futuro los productos de origen animal?
No tienen que parecerse a esto,
que es la realidad del estado actual de las cosas.
Más bien, podrá ser mucho mejor.
Ya hemos estado fabricando con cultivos celulares,
durante miles de años; productos
como el vino, la cerveza y el yogurt.
Y hablando de comida, la comida cultivada ha evolucionado
y hoy se preparan los alimentos cultivados
en bellas instalaciones estériles como ésta.
Una fábrica de cerveza es esencialmente un biorreactor.
Es el lugar donde se lleva a cabo el cultivo de células.
Imaginen que en esta instalación,
en lugar de la elaboración de cerveza,
estuviéramos elaborando cuero
o carne.
Imagínense recorriendo esta instalación,
aprendiendo cómo se cultiva el cuero o la carne,
viendo el proceso de principio a fin,
e incluso probándolos.
Es limpio, abierto y educativo,
y esto va en contraste con las fábricas
ocultas, vigiladas y remotas
donde el cuero y la carne se producen hoy en día.
Tal vez la biofabricación
es la evolución natural de fabricación para la humanidad.
Es responsable con el medioambiente,
eficiente y humanitaria.
Nos permite ser creativos.
Podemos diseñar nuevos materiales, nuevos productos,
y nuevas instalaciones.
Tenemos que dejar atrás el sacrificio de animales
como único recurso
y llegar a algo más civilizado y evolucionado.
Tal vez estamos listos para algo,
literal y figuradamente, más cultivado.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)